Tim Ferriss: So Shane,
there are a million and one places we could start.
So my understanding is you were a straight D
student till grade 10, if I'm getting that right.
And maybe this is a segue, maybe it isn't, but
why was the book The Stopwatch Gang
important to you and could you provide
some context for how that appeared in your life?
Shane Parrish: So my parents were in the military.
I lived with my mom and my stepfather, my
biological father lived somewhere else,
and we moved every year. So every year I had
a new school. I think the first school that I
went to two years in a row was grade 10 and
11, to put things in context, same school,
two years in a row. For grade eight, I decided
I was going to live with my biological father.
So I moved across the country, lived with
him, and for various reasons, this was
a disaster. Somebody who really didn't have a
lot of experience parenting me growing up all
of a sudden has a teenager, my stepmother all of a
sudden inheriting a teenager, living in the middle
of nowhere. I'm already a borderline delinquent.
I almost got kicked out of school in grade seven
for skipping school. I skipped school for seven or
eight weeks, had to go see a child psychologist to
make sure, as a condition of not being expelled,
that there was nothing seriously wrong with me.
And so in grade eight, I just started getting
in more and more trouble. I started hanging
around the wrong people. Your environment sort
of determines your behavior a lot, not only your
physical environment, but the people you surround
yourself with. And it's just the slow escalation.
And if somebody said, "Hey, you're going to go
break into somebody's house," you'd never do
it. But if you start with vandalism, and you start
staying out late, and you start doing things that
you're not supposed to, all of a sudden vandalism
or breaking into a house is the next logical step.
So we're doing this book report for
grade eight, and I go to the library,
and I'm not interested in reading, I'm not
even interested in doing my schoolwork at all.
And I just happened to land in this true
crime section at this elementary school,
which is like four books long. And there's one
book called The Stopwatch Gang. And I was like,
what's this about? I pick it up and it's about
a bunch of bank robbers. And I was like, oh,
this is awesome. This is my kind of book. Why
has nobody shown me that you can read about
this stuff? So I get home, and I'm reading this
book, and a few days later, my friends knock on
the door. And we all had dirt bikes. So we're all
living on 20 acres. You're commuting by dirt bike
to your friend's house. They knock on the door —
Tim Ferriss: And where are
you at this point in time?
Shane Parrish: This is in Carp, Ontario, Canada.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Okay.
Just to place it for people.
Shane Parrish: So they knock on the door,
and they're like, "Come out with us and
let's have some fun." And I was one chapter away
from the end, and I don't know, you've probably
read a really good book, and you want nothing
to interrupt you in that moment. You're like,
no, the world doesn't exist. I need to finish
this book. There's nothing more important. So
I lied because if I told them I was reading a book
that would go over a lead balloon, but I was like,
"I'm not really feeling that well tonight. I'm
going to stay in. I'm sorry about that." And
so they go out, and they end up breaking into
somebody's house and getting caught and a whole
bunch of bad things happened as a result of that.
And if I was there, I probably would've been doing
that with them, but luckily I wasn't there.
I didn't do that with them. I found out about
what happened, and this is a chance event. This
wasn't me thinking about anything and saying no
to this thing. It was just pure 100 percent
luck. But I sort of got a little bit scared
straight after that, not in terms of "I'm going
to devote myself to schoolwork and get better
grades," but straight in the sense of "I don't
want to do this. I don't want to get into this
trouble." And then from that moment on, books sort
of became an outlet for me to live in an imaginary
world and to escape the world I was actually
in and to sort of be part of something else.
Have you ever had a book do that to you?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, for sure. I literally,
yesterday, this is not something I should
probably advertise broadly. I'm not proud of it,
but I was listening to the second of three
books in this trilogy by Joe Abercrombie,
and I had six minutes left in this very, very good
chapter, and my mom had arrived a little bit early
to go to dinner. And so I was banking on having
that extra time before the pickup to finish this
chapter. And it bothered me so much that I got
up, I said I really had to go to the bathroom,
and I went to the bathroom, and I just
walked around outside the restaurant
for six minutes and finished this chapter in
the audiobook. That was last night. So yes,
I definitely know the feeling.
Shane Parrish: That's awesome.
And you're like, "How dare you show up early?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, which is not the tone I want to
take with my mom, but I was like, oh, okay, yeah,
I forgot my OCD as it applies to time should not
be imposed on all other people, so that's okay.
Took a little loitering meander as a bathroom
break at dinner. That's okay. Got it done.
Shane Parrish: And then in grade nine, my grade
nine teacher wrote in my report card that "Shane
would be lucky to graduate from high school."
Tim Ferriss: So what happened? A couple
of observations. Number one, if you had
been convicted of, I'm not sure what the legal
equivalent is, something like a felony or whatever
that was with your friends, that certainly, I
would imagine, would've complicated later work
in government on some level.
Shane Parrish: Oh, totally.
Tim Ferriss: Or it could have. What were
the inflection points that led to you being
employable, especially at an
intelligence agency, in 2001?
Shane Parrish: Okay, so that is also a crazy story
because intelligence agencies, they vet people up,
down. They interviewed neighbors, they interviewed
teachers, they interviewed the references that I
put down. They talked to people that I didn't put
down. They want to know about your life. They want
to know who you are as a person, especially for
students and for people like me who have a bit
more of a, I would say, troubled background. I'm
not a straight-A student. I didn't go to the best
schools in life. I had a clean record, but if
you look at this sort of supporting evidence,
it's like, well, this person's been in
trouble over the course of their life,
and they talked to my professors, and one
of my professors hated me. And so that
conversation was like, it was just so weird.
We had this, I don't know if other people
had this, but in physics, first-year physics,
they had this computer program that generated
your assignments for you. So everybody
in the class literally had this different
assignment and each question was different.
There was 10 versions of question one,
and then all the numbers were different. So even
if you had the same version of question one, that
you could find somebody else with it, you had the
same version, you would have different numbers,
so you couldn't just copy the answer. So all
the kids in school, all the rich kids basically,
bought the same tutor, and this tutor for 20
bucks or whatever, you gave him your sheet and
he spit out the answers for you because he had
all the 10 versions of the question. He would
just plug in your numbers, and you'd go to school.
And the way to submit your assignment wasn't you
actually submitted paper. This is the dawn
of the internet, like 1998-ish. And so you
would submit your assignment almost like over
Telnet. You would log in and it would say,
"What's your answer to question one?"
And you would submit your answer. And
I was like, this takes a lot of time. I've got
to work full-time. I don't know if I can spend
the 20 hours a week it actually takes to do this.
But I was in computer science, so it was like I'll
write a little program that just sort of goes from
-1000 to 1000 and guesses in increments of 0.1.
And so I did this little program and it worked
great. I got 20 out of 20 on every assignment
until March of my first year. The teacher comes
in and he used one of those transparencies,
and I don't know if people remember
transparencies, but basically —
Tim Ferriss: The overhead projectors.
Shane Parrish: So it's like a PowerPoint
graph that he puts on this projector, and it's
like average guesses on the y-axis and student
number on the x-axis. And the average number
of guesses per question was, I don't know,
17 or something. And mine was in the millions.
So he's like, "I want to see this student
after class." And I was careful. I had
read all the policies and procedures,
and it says, "Unlimited guessing."
Tim Ferriss: So you're submitting like a
million guesses via Telnet, is that right?
Shane Parrish: Yeah, I'm not doing
anything. I just basically —
Tim Ferriss: So there's no downside
for number of guesses. You're only rewarded for
getting the answer right in one of those guesses.
Shane Parrish: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, so why not? Yeah.
Shane Parrish: I read all the policies and
procedures. I was very careful about reading
all the rules to make sure I wasn't violating
any rules. But I would go to bed, and I would
just basically hit run on this program,
and I would wake up, and I would have my
full assignments submitted, 20 out of 20.
Tim Ferriss: So Shane gets retained after
class. Was it to discipline you and wag
a finger at you, or was there something
else that came with the conversation?
Shane Parrish: Oh, so he was like, "You're
going to get zero on all your assignments."
And I was like, "What? That's not fair at all."
And he's like, "Well, we're sort of retroactively
changing the rules." And I was like, "That doesn't
make any sense. That's not fair. All the
rich kids are hiring tutors. I can't do
that. It doesn't make sense. Just go with
my exam mark as my mark," sort of thing.
And he said "No." And basically, the
assignments were so heavily weighted
that I ended up failing physics because of this.
It was so crazy. And so when I'm getting my job,
they actually talked to this teacher.
Tim Ferriss: Now how did you come in
touch with — I understand why he would have an ax
to grind or at least it sounds like the kind of
guy who would have maybe something scornful and
spiteful to say. How did you even get connected
with an intelligence agency? Were they recruiting
in certain centers nearby? Did they canvas the
whole country? I don't know how it works.
Shane Parrish: It was just sort of luck. I
was doing computer science at a time when the rise
of the internet. I didn't want to work for Nortel
or any of these big companies. I really wanted to
work for an intelligence agency. I thought that
would be really fun and coincidence that they
happen to be at my school. I like problems that
are not really solvable, that are intractable,
that are big and gnarly and that you can never
quite solve, but you can get better at. My parents
were in the military, so I had a patriotic sense
of giving back to my country. How fortunate
am I to be born into a country with freedom
and good school system and a good healthcare
system? And I was taught and brought up in a
way that you have an obligation to give back.
And for anybody that knows me, I'm not going
to give back standing on the front lines with a
machine gun. That's just dangerous for everybody
involved. But if I could use my brain in a
way that was giving back to the people and
the community and the country in which I grew up,
I thought that that was a really good win-win,
interesting problems, giving back at the same
time. They came to the school, I applied for
a job, and if I didn't get it, I was basically
going to go back and do my MBA right away and do
something else. But I ended up getting it, ended
up working with an incredible group of talented
people starting what then went on to become
the largest part of the intelligence agency
I think now, or the most valuable part of it.
Tim Ferriss: And for people in the US what would
that agency be comparable to, if you can say?
Would it be comparable to the NSA, comparable to
CIA, comparable to other three-letter acronym?
Shane Parrish: Yeah, that would be the NSA.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, got it. And I am going
to take a hard left here to ask you about,
maybe since you like intractable problems,
to ask you about one that I know a lot of my
friends are contending with, which is thinking
about how moving around helps or handicaps their
kids. You moved around a ton. You have kids.
How do you think that experience of moving
from place to place, school to school,
affected you positively and negatively,
or in the pro and con columns, so to speak?
And how do you think about that or how would
you suggest other people think about that if
they currently have very mobile lives and are
wondering how that will affect their kids?
Shane Parrish: There's a couple different
ways to think about that as it
relates to my experience, which is
I knew I was moving, so I knew at the end of the
year I was going to be in a different school.
That became apparent at least by grade six or
seven. And so every year I could experiment
with myself and not consciously, but
I could emphasize different parts of
myself. Do I fit in with the jocks? Do I
fit in with the nerds? What is my group of
people? And I could play a role for a year.
The downside is I knew that I was moving in
a year, and so I knew all of these relationships
were sort of transitory. So I think the biggest
impact it had on me is, even in adulthood, it took
me a long time to sort of develop "This person's
going to be in my life for a long period of time.
This isn't like a transitory relationship," and
transitory means it is just going to go. And so
you don't invest in it. You don't invest in it
the same way that you would invest in your best
friend or somebody like that because you knew
the closer you got to that person at the end
of the year, the harder it would be to leave.
And so at that point in time, it was
really difficult for me coming out of that,
becoming a university student, and then joining
the workforce, to not have this mental default
of this is going to go away or I might not see
this person? But on the flipside, it's like,
I'm going to work with this person for the next
15 years. And I think that was really hard for me
to sort of catch on to. It took a few years for me
to really start investing in those friendships and
those relationships in the way that I wanted to.
Tim Ferriss: If you were sitting at a dinner table
with some, let's say they're relatively new
parents, they have kids under the age of two,
so the kids aren't going to school for a little
bit, but it's not the distant future. And they
have a life where they spend X number of months
in one place and Y number of months in another,
and maybe they're thinking about living in
a different state or a different country,
but they don't want to screw their kids up
in maybe indulging those explorations. At
the same time, they're not sure if they
want to be in one place in a fixed way.
What would you say to those people?
Shane Parrish: My advice, for what it's
worth, is I don't think it really matters much
until they're sort of grade seven and eight,
and certainly in high school. It matters a lot in
high school, the consistency, the friend group,
the sort of knowing what to expect. Because
if I map myself to just my kids and their age,
there's a lot of uncertainty in their life.
There's a lot of things going on that we don't
see. And then adding on to that sort of like
you're going to be in a different school with a
different system with the different teachers, you
can't really thrive in that environment easily.
That doesn't mean you can't thrive. It just
means you're making it harder than it has to be.
But before that, I would say up until grade six,
again, just going on my experience with my kids,
what they're really learning in school and from
friendships is how do we be social? How do we
interact with other people? How do we get in
the habit of going to school? How do we learn
to read and learn to do basic math? And that you
can sort of get anywhere in the world really,
really easily. Grade seven, at least for
my kids, is when it started to change,
and that's in part because of the schools that I
sent them to. I think it starts to matter in grade
seven increasingly and definitely in high school.
Tim Ferriss: What type of
schools did you send them to?
Shane Parrish: I'm a big believer that kids should
be challenged. And I don't think that the schools
around my house challenged the kids. So I found a
school in Ottawa that I had to drive to and drop
off my kids. And I'm the type of parent that's
like, "You can do things you don't believe you're
capable of." And so starting in grade seven, my
kids were getting 90 minutes of homework a night,
they were taking school in a different language,
and they were pushed and challenged. And the
standards of this school, and I take a lot of
flack for this even from friends of mine, but
the standards of this school are unrelenting.
They don't care how you feel. And that is
very counter-cultural in today's message.
But if you go in there and you haven't done your
homework, it does not matter. You get a zero.
And to put things in context, we went to my
grandmother's funeral in May, and they were
one day late getting their essay in, and they
were one day late, and they got 10 percent off
their essay because they were one day late. And
the school's approach to this is like, look, we
want to produce effective adults, and that means
you're going to fail in grade seven. You're not
going to fail academically because everybody there
is really smart. You're going to fail at these
little life things that you should have taken
that into account when you planned your essay
submission. And they put it on the students, and
they do it in such a way that the kids, at first,
my son was crying every night because he is
naturally really, really smart. And he goes to
the school, and it's in a different language, and
now it's 90 minutes of work a night and they're —
Tim Ferriss: Is it French? What is the language?
Shane Parrish: Yeah, so it's French. And so I
don't speak French. I didn't speak French to him
at home. He hasn't spoken French in two and a
half years because of COVID basically. And all
of a sudden, he's thrust into a French school,
and they're unrelenting. So he was so naturally
smart that he didn't have to work for anything,
and that school eliminates that. They're like,
"No, you have to work and if you don't work, you
can't get good grades." And it was so hard on him,
and I'm the parent who's like, "Hey, I love you.
I know this is really hard. I know you can do it.
Let's shift our mindset around this." And by the
end of, I would say, December, he was loving it.
He loved being challenged. And when it came time
to pick a high school, he literally, his filter
was what school is going to challenge me the most?
And I was like, "Oh, that school did an awesome
job." I'm so happy that that's the way he's
thinking about this. It's not about grades. I
would rather him basically fail at doing something
hard than really succeed at doing something easy
because I feel like we get wrapped up as parents,
our kids' success is our success, and so
their grades become our success. But really,
what we want to do is produce independent adults
who are capable of handling the ups and downs of
life. And that means that they're going to fail,
they're going to struggle, they're going to have
teachers they don't like, they're going to get
grades that maybe they do or don't deserve.
And so I think about all of these things.
Tim Ferriss: I would say an example of
a similar experience in the sense that I
went to a very easy, reasonably disorganized
set of schools up until the end of my
freshman year in high school and then
was transferred, and this was my idea, but I
transferred to a very difficult school, for me
at least, in New Hampshire, boarding school. And I
got absolutely crushed, schooling six days a week,
mandatory sports every semester. You had classes,
also, sixth period, I think it was, after sports,
and then you would have seated meals with coat
and tie and so on several times a week and the
whole nine, and was so challenging. I went from
being easily top of the pack to maybe bottom of
the middle of the pack, maybe lower, right? I was
suddenly undistinguished from any intellectual
perspective. And kids who were at this school,
St. Paul's, knew how to work, too, a lot of them.
And I'm so grateful for it because they were
incredibly tough, discipline was demanded,
and everything after that was relatively
easy, even Princeton and so on, the workload,
no problem. And I think in retrospect that it
was really critical to my formation. That's
also where I was introduced to Japanese and
other languages and had my exchange experience,
which changed everything for me. But being taught
early that the world will not conform to all of
your unique needs and preferences is, like you
said, it's very counter-cultural. I don't think
if you train a child to expect, this is true,
train anyone to expect they are going to drive
decisions, what they want is always going
to be taken into account, what they like is
always going to be at the top of other priority
lists, it's setting them up for a lifetime of
disappointment and disorder and depression
probably, all at once. Anyway, that's maybe
a strong response, but I agree with the approach.
Shane Parrish: Pause for one sec. I want to know,
you said this was your decision. What made
you decide that? Where did that come from?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I guess it was informed
by a couple of other inputs. So one was,
I was very lucky. Luck plays into all of this so
much. One friend of mine had escaped Long Island,
and he had gone to St. Paul's, and he came back,
and he basically said, "You've got to get out of
here. You have to escape." And it happened that
around the same time, I think it was a math
teacher and one other teacher effectively said
the same thing. They're like, "Tim, I can't go any
faster, but you're not going to get what you need
here." And there wasn't really a strong suggestion
as to a solution in that case. But those things
all combined to piquing my curiosity about these
things called boarding school. I didn't know
what boarding schools were, outside of a few
stories from my friend's experience. So I went
to the local library back when you had to do
this and took out these really thick guides to
boarding schools, tried to figure things out,
and ultimately got a few scholarships. And
then my whole extended family helped pay
for this thing because it's expensive. And my
immediate family didn't have very much money.
So I was very lucky that my grandparents and
other people also chipped in to make it happen.
And I think that fundamentally, I had also been
competing in sports. And I recognized in sports,
if you're not losing routinely, you're
not training with the right people.
Does that make sense? At least in wrestling. It's
like if you were to train on a tennis team and
your goal was to become the best tennis player
possible, if you are just annihilating the team,
you're kind of on the wrong team if your goal
is to compete in larger and larger arenas. So
I appreciated that and enjoyed that with respect
to competition. I was very competitive. But I
couldn't really apply that to the academics in any
meaningful way until I went to St. Paul's and then
I got my ass kicked. But it was the beneficial
adaptive ass-kicking that I think I really needed.
Shane Parrish: I think we miss
that, right? School has become
almost too easy. We're not challenging the kids
and we're not holding them to a high enough
standard, and it's causing all these downstream
problems later on in life. At least that's my
view. And I want my kids to be challenged. I want
them to fail. I want them to learn how to overcome
these obstacles. And you must've gone through
something similar when you're going from sort
of lead dog to maybe bottom, middle of the pack.
"Where's my identity?" You're not just dealing
with, "How do I develop the systems to study and
get the work done? And all these people already
know it, so I'm behind." But you're dealing
with all these identity crises in terms of
your ego and how you think about yourself.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, totally. For the first six
months, I felt like I was always behind. I was
always behind. I was always having to choose
what I wouldn't finish because I just was not
fast enough. I was not organized enough. I did
not have the time management skills and figuring
out when I could take a 20-minute nap so that I
could then stay up an extra hour and a half
after dinner to finish A, B, and C, and then
manage to do this other thing in preparation so
that I'd be well-prepared for athletic practice
the next day after a full day of coursework,
after chapel every morning just about. I think
it was six days a week we had chapel, either
five or six days, which is mostly roll call of
sorts and announcements. But there were also
hymns and this, that, and the other thing.
It was a very, very full schedule. And I'm
grateful for that. And people listening have
probably heard the expression, "If you want
something done, give it to a busy man." It
could be woman, of course. But the idea being if
someone is busy and they have a full schedule,
they learn how to juggle that full schedule.
And if you have an incomplete schedule,
I think especially in those formative years in
high school, you do not by necessity develop the
time management skills that if you really want to
charge hard later in life, you are going to need.
And I feel lucky, very, very lucky. If I hadn't
had that friend who was the proof of concept,
who knows? Who knows where I would be?
So let's come back to your life story.
What was 68131, I think it was .blogger.com
if I'm getting that right. What was that?
Shane Parrish: So when I was working at the
intelligence agency, I started two weeks before
September 11th. Literally, two weeks later,
the world changed and everybody was thrust
into roles and responsibilities over the coming
decade, basically, that they weren't ready for,
nobody could have prepared you
for, you just had to do your best.
And I remember being put in charge of something
that I didn't feel like I could quite handle. And
I'm making decisions that sort of impact
myself and impact my team and impact my
country and impact troops in theater. And
I have no idea what I'm doing. And so I
went to my boss one day after a particularly
challenging operation. I said, "Here's how
I thought about it. I don't think I'm ready
for this job. I don't think I can do this."
And he basically just looked at me and
he was like, "You're all we've got.
What else are we going to do? We're all just doing
the best we can. Get back to work." And I was
like, "That's the worst pep talk I have ever heard
in my life." And so I was like, "I think people
deserve better than me. And what can I do if I
can't sort get out of this role?" So I started
following people around in the organization. I
was like, "How do these people make decisions?
What can I learn from them?" And I went back and
did an MBA. And when I was doing my MBA, I just
rediscovered Charlie Munger and Warren Buffett.
And part of my MBA, it was so useless. And I don't
mean that in a negative way, it just wasn't giving
me what I needed at that particular moment to get
better at the things that I wanted to get better
at. But Charlie Munger and Warren Buffett were.
And so I created this website, which was
68131-1440.blogger.com, which I don't own
today. Somebody else has, like, taken this
over, probably because I talk about it a lot.
But the website was basically the ZIP code for
Berkshire Hathaway, dash, the unit number of
Berkshire Hathaway in Kiewit Plaza. And it was my
online journal. Now keep in mind, this is like — I
don't know what year it is, but I'm not allowed to
have a LinkedIn profile. I'm not allowed to have
any social — you Google me, I do not exist. The
intelligence agency would be livid if you had any
sort of public profile, any sort of anything at
all. And here I am, I'm like, "Oh, I'm just going
to create this online journal and this is how I'm
going to chronicle my learning and development.
I'm just going to take notes and I'm going to
connect these ideas and I'm going to synthesize
them and I'm going to compress them. And that is
the act of reflection. So I'm going to basically
learn things on my own. I'm going to reflect on
them, and then I'm going to write about them."
And so I started this website. And then
eventually, I don't even know how at this point,
we got to, I think it was like 25,000 readers
or something. And then all of a sudden I started
getting these emails, which is like, "I hate
typing in the name of your website. Can you
basically change the name?" And I was like, "Fine.
I'll just call it Farnam Street," which was the
homage to Buffett and Munger, who I know have
played such a critical role in your life too.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, they have. I remember somebody,
I can't recall who it was, but dug up the video
of my wavering voice at the Berkshire Hathaway
shareholder meeting when I asked my question
from the nosebleed seats. I have been informed
by them for sure. I have incredible respect for
both of them. Were you introduced to them by
Buffett: The Making of an American Capitalist,
or how did you get introduced to them?
Shane Parrish: Yeah, so I read Buffett:
The Making of an American Capitalist, I think in
university. But everything got put on the back
burner once I joined the intelligence agency
and the world changed. September 11th changed
everything. I didn't really come up. I worked
six days a week, 12 hours a day for years,
didn't really have a lot of vacations,
didn't have a lot of long weekends,
and everybody else was doing the exact same thing.
And it was the best time of my life if that makes
sense too. Not only you're working incredibly
hard, you're working on amazing problems that
you're really attracted to, and you're working
with a group of highly intelligent, dedicated
people. It doesn't really get much better than
that from a quality-of-life point of view.
But everything, all these outside interests
got put on hold. I'm coming home, I'm spending
a little bit of time with the woman who was my
girlfriend at the time. And then I'm going to
bed and I'm waking up and just repeating on rinse.
And then the MBA was sort of a way for me to step
back from that for a couple years, do a less
intensive role there while doing a full-time
MBA. And that was when I got reconnected. I was
like, "Oh, yeah, this Warren Buffett guy and
Charlie Munger. But what are they doing? They're
making decisions in the real world and they seem
really good at it. So what can I learn from that?"
Tim Ferriss: When you had the somewhat awkward
numerical string, right, when you had the
ZIP code as the URL, if you remember, were
there any particular pieces that struck a chord
with folks? Those are nontrivial numbers you're
talking about in terms of readership. Were there
any particular threads or pieces that come to mind
that really struck a chord in the early days?
Shane Parrish: I'd have to go back to be sure,
but I think there's stuff about — I was trying
to figure out how Daniel Kahneman came up with
cognitive biases. And Warren Buffett and Charlie
Munger didn't really talk about cognitive biases,
but seemed to avoid them. And so I spent
a lot of time trying to reconcile how
cognitive biases can help you in the real world.
And so what I sort of hit on, at least from my
point of view, is cognitive biases are really good
at explaining why you made a mistake in the past,
but they're really poor at preventing you
from making mistakes in the future. So they're
intellectually very satisfying, but they don't
really prevent you — if you create a checklist of
cognitive biases and you're a smart person, you're
just basically going to outsmart yourself. "Am I
overconfident? No, I'm not overconfident,"
right? "I've got this, I did the work." And
so the story you tell yourself, you sort of
talk yourself out of them in a lot of ways,
which is a bit of an irony to them.
Tim Ferriss: Now tell me more about that.
What do you mean by talking yourself out of them?
Shane Parrish: Well, you come up with a checklist.
A lot of people have tried this. They come up with
a checklist of cognitive biases and they're like,
"Okay, I'm going to see if this applies to me."
Tim Ferriss: So sunk cost fallacy, this, that,
and the other thing, expectancy
bias, or whatever it might be.
Just putting together a list of
things that one is intending to avoid.
Shane Parrish: Yes, yeah. But considers sunk
cost. So you make a decision and then you pull
out your checklist and you're like, "Am I
considering sunk cost or am I just making
this fresh?" And you've already decided at
this moment. So you're just justifying and
rationalizing the decision you already have.
Tim Ferriss: I see what you're saying.
Shane Parrish: You tell yourself a story
about why sunk cost doesn't apply in this
situation or why you're not overconfident
in this situation. And the smarter you are —
Tim Ferriss: Use confirmation
bias to address your other biases.
Shane Parrish: Exactly, right? And
the smarter you are, the better those
stories get and the more believable they get.
Tim Ferriss: Actually, I'd love to get your
help defining a phrase, just I suppose explaining
a phrase and then segueing into a conversation
around mental models and cognitive biases and so
on. So ordinary moments determine your position,
and your position determines your
results. So what is meant by that
line and what is meant by position?
Shane Parrish: So the counterintuitive
insight that I had about decision-making
from studying sort of Buffett and Munger and
Peter Kaufman and a host of other people who've
influenced my thinking is that they almost never
find themselves out of position. And if you want
to think of it as position as your circumstances,
they're never forced by circumstances into
doing something that they don't want to do.
And often that means they look like an idiot
in the short term, but in the long term,
they win. If you consider Buffett, for example,
we've talked about he closes down his partnership
during a bull market in the '60s because he
doesn't know how to invest anymore. He's lost
touch. He can't find what worked for him. He
reopens it later in terms of Berkshire Hathaway.
Time magazine, I think it was 1999, he's
on the cover as being out of touch. 2001,
stock market burst. Right now, as of today, I
think as of last quarter, he's got 150 billion
dollars on the balance sheet. And so what he's
always doing is everybody thinks he's out of touch
and he looks like an idiot. But he always wins
because no matter what the outcome is, he wins.
If the stock market goes up, he wins. If the stock
market crashes, he wins because he's put himself
in a position where no matter what happens, he can
take advantage of circumstances rather than having
circumstances take advantage of him. And I think
that that's a key element we don't realize. If you
put Warren Buffett in a bad position where all of
his options are bad, it doesn't matter how smart
he is, it doesn't matter how Warren Buffett he is.
Everybody looks like an idiot when they're in a
bad position and everybody looks like a
genius when they're in a good position.
Tim Ferriss: Do you then create that position by
having a handful of commandments? And I'm making
these up. I'm not saying this is what Buffett
does because I haven't tracked him as closely
as you have. But for instance, I know someone
who's cut from a similar cloth. And he's like,
"No short positions, no leverage." And he has
four or five rules that he follows, which means
he doesn't always beat the S&P 500, let's say,
but he's very rarely in a position where he's
a distressed seller or is forced into a bad
position. So he's able to play a very long
game. So I guess please keep going. But
I'm wondering how you consistently create
that type of position, if that makes sense.
Shane Parrish: So let me talk about it in
terms of finance and then apply it to something
else that's totally — you would think it doesn't
apply to. So in finance, you can think of
low debt, you can think of saving money,
you can think of always having dry powder. It
doesn't matter if you have the best idea in the
world. If you can't take advantage of that idea,
you might as well not have the idea. You have to
be in a position to take advantage of the ideas
that you have. And you have to be in a position
where somebody can't call you in at the exact
wrong moment because that's really expensive,
as everybody sort of learned during the
great financial crisis and has now forgotten.
We seem to relearn these lessons over and
over again. But positioning applies to so
many other things that we don't think about.
And you can think about it basically as in
your sleep. Did you work out? Are you healthy?
Are you eating well? Are you investing in your
relationship with your partner? What position am I
in the moment that I get into a fight or argument
or disagreement with my partner or my spouse? And
we don't think about the position we're in at that
moment. But if you imagine that there's a patch
of grass between you and them, is that grass dry
or is it wet? Have I watered that for months, in
which case the spark isn't going to light it on
fire, or is the smallest little spark going to
start this forest fire? And the position that
we bring into those arguments matters a lot in
terms of the quality of the outcomes that we get.
And I'll give you another example. We were
talking about kids earlier, and I assume a
lot of people listening have kids. One of my
kids came home with an exam and he got a really
terrible mark. And he hands it to me. And he's
like a teenager, so he hands it to me, he's like,
"I did the best I could," walks away. And normally
the conversation ends there. And I was like,
"Okay. Now is not the moment that we're going
to talk about this because I know we've got this
teenage attitude thing going on, but we're going
to circle back to this." And so later that night
I was like, "Talk to me about what it means to
do the best you can." And what he told me about
the best he could was when he sat down to write
that test from 10:00 to 11:00, he focused all of
his energy and all of his effort on it. He made
the best decisions possible from 10:00 to 11:00.
But what he forgot or didn't really appreciate is
what position was he in at 10:00 a.m. when he sat
down to write that test? Did he fight with his
brother in the morning? Yep, he did. Did he eat
a healthy breakfast? Nope, he didn't. Did he get
a good night's sleep? Nope. He was up late. Did
he study? No, he sort of half-assed it. And so
what happened was he was in a bad position at
the moment he sat down to write that test. He was
ill-prepared to write the test, but yes, he did
the best he could in that moment. And so often
we think about life in terms of, "How do I do
the best I can in this particular moment?" rather
than, "How do I put myself in the best position?"
And part of that is we're always predicting, we're
predicting creatures. And so we're always trying
to gauge what the outcome is and maximize towards
that outcome. "I want to go all in on Tesla,
I want to go all in on whatever I want to maximize
my return." And what we don't think about is like,
"Okay. Well, what is the cost of doing that?
And what if I'm wrong? And how do I position
myself for multiple possible futures where,
what if my idea is not correct? Can I still
survive and can I thrive on that?" And if you
look back and you sort of look back at Carnegie
and Rockefeller and all these historical
people who built these great businesses,
including Buffett, they always take
advantage of a weakness in somebody
else's position when their position is strong.
Tim Ferriss: Who else would you, and I know you
mentioned a few names, but outside of Buffett
and Munger, who else would you put on your
shortlist? And not to make you pick favorites,
I'm sure you give a very long list. But just
off the cuff, if you had to pick five to
10 people let's just say, could be four,
but let's aim for five or slightly more people
who you really respect as incisive, deliberate
decision-makers. Who would make that list?
Shane Parrish: So we have a mutual friend,
Naval Ravikant. He could be up there. Patrick
Collison would sort of be up there. Kat Cole,
who works at Athletic Greens.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
Shane Parrish: One of my favorite people.
She's always one step ahead. She's amazing.
I think that there's very few people
who are well-positioned in everything.
If you look at somebody who's extremely good
at one thing like Buffett, that comes with
extreme weaknesses. But you can have a list
of exemplars in your head almost of different
people who are good at different positions. But
you have to pick what direction you're going.
And then what positions do you need to be good
at to be good in that direction? And so for me,
I circle back to core things which people don't
really think about, but they're core to everything
we do in terms of health and relationships
and friendship and purpose and community. Am I
working on something that I want to be working
on? Am I moving closer to my destination and
is my destination the place I want to go?
And I think those questions are stuff that
we don't really ask ourselves. We're always so
focused on, "How do we accomplish the outcome
we want?" rather than, "What are the key elements
to this process that allow me to play for a long
time? Am I going in the right direction
and do I want to get to where I'm going?"
Tim Ferriss: So I am going to come back to
just the broad question of how to incorporate
thinking about cognitive biases if I'm
saying that correctly and/or mental.
I guess those are different. I'd love to
have you — let's begin there. How would you
distinguish or define mental models? And then
I'm going to go micro and then we'll zoom out.
Shane Parrish: So a great way to think about
mental models is the source of all bad decisions
is blind spots. Mental models allow you to see
a problem through a different lens. You can
adopt a different persona. A great example of
a mental model is like, "How would Tim Ferriss
think about this?" And then I adapt what I know
about you and I try to see the problem from your
perspective. And if I can see the problem from
your perspective, now I've done the one thing that
actually gets me out of cognitive biases, which is
the source of all cognitive biases are basically
we believe that what we see is all there is.
And we learned about this sort of in physics in
grade nine I think where you're standing on this
train and you're carrying this ball. And the train
is moving at 60 miles an hour, and how fast is the
ball moving? Well, relative to you, the ball's not
moving. But if you're watching the train go by,
the ball's moving at 60 miles an hour. And so
the source of all of our problems is that we only
see that we're this person on the train holding
this ball, and we can't see that there's a person
outside who has a completely different view into
the exact same situation that we see. So we can
mentally use these tools to sort of accommodate
how we can look into the world from a different
person's eyes or through a different lens, be
that biology or through thinking or through — the
most useful ones tend to be like, "And then what?"
Just asking yourself that simple question, "I
accomplish this and then what happens?" Inversion,
"How do I avoid all these negative outcomes that I
don't want to get?" And the Stoics, you've talked
about this in the past, the Stoics have been doing
this for a long time. They call it a pre-mortem.
I think that those are just really helpful ways.
And what they're really doing is they're just
allowing us to put a different lens onto the
problem and see it through a different light.
And by seeing it through a different light, we
slightly reduce our blind spots into the problem.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally. I haven't read these
in decades, so caveat lector for anyone who picks
these up. But some of Edward de Bono's
work, I think he's originally Maltese,
so de Bono's two words, or actually he may
just be a Maltese citizen. I can't peg the
nationality. It doesn't really matter. He wrote a
book called Lateral Thinking. He has another one,
I think it's called The Six Thinking
Hats or something along those lines,
which similarly, very helpful just for forcing
yourself as a portion of a practice to look at the
same situation with a different lens, a different
set of questions, a different perspective.
I'd love to talk to you about Farnam Street, but
more broadly building a business/life/businesses
on content, on advice, on writing, and
also certainly audio. But if you look
back post-intelligence agency on what
you have built, what are some of the
more important decisions that you have made or
more important experiments that you have run,
whether they turned out as you had hoped or not?
Shane Parrish: I think building a business on
content is really hard. I think I never set out
to build a media company. What I set out to do
was learn timeless ideas from other people and
master the best of what other people have figured
out and share that with the world as a means of
giving back. And part of what I want to do in life
is leave the world a better place than I found it.
And I believe in equal opportunity and not equal
outcome. But how can we have equal opportunity if
we don't share information with people and make it
accessible? So that's how I stumbled into Farnam
Street. And there's been these pivotal moments
along the way, and some are intentional and some
are just completely random. An example of which is
I never had email. I never got people
to sign up for email until FeedBurner.
Remember when FeedBurner went away?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I do, I do.
Shane Parrish: Right. So I lost three-quarters
of my audience overnight because Google decided
to shut down this thing. And then at that
moment it dawned on me, "How can somebody
else take away my audience from me? No, that's
not cool. How do I solve for this problem?" And
so I started an email list and now we have
600,000 or 700,000 people on the email list,
and I sent out an email every Sunday, basically
what I'm learning. But that was the moment. I'd
never thought about, "How do I create an email
list?" Or, "I need this." It was like somebody
took away my — Facebook has done the same thing.
Twitter to varying extents has done the same
thing. They basically take your audience away from
you and then you become platform-dependent. And I
don't want to be platform-dependent. I don't
want anybody to be between me and the people
who've chosen to read me and get my ideas.
Tim Ferriss: So what are the components of
your business as it exists today? And then I'm
happy to have a conversation about this. I'm
just fascinated how different people approach
things, especially since we're talking about,
among other things, decision-making and so
on. So I'd love to know how it breaks down
currently because you've got online
courses, you have the podcast,
you have other things. How does the business,
so to speak, breakdown as it stands right now?
Shane Parrish: So we do a few things.
You remember that diagram from Disney
in the '60s and they have theme parks and
merchandise and how it all interconnects?
You can look this up on the internet.
Tim Ferriss: I don't, but I would love
to find it. All right, I'll find it.
Shane Parrish: So with Farnam Street —
Tim Ferriss: And we'll put it in the show notes.
Shane Parrish: Yeah. So my idea with Farnam Street
was sort of, how do I create more surface area
for people to discover timeless content or that
they master the best of what other people have
figured out? So it's literally not about me,
it's about other people's ideas. I don't
really have any original ideas. I sort of,
if anything, maybe compress other
people's ideas in an interesting way.
And so we started with a website and then we went
to a podcast and then the podcast, interesting
side note here, Naval Ravikant saved the podcast
because I was doing this podcast and I was like,
"Nobody's listening to this podcast." And I had
just recorded with Naval. And I was like, "That's
the last episode I'm going to do." And then of
course that episode goes parabolic. And I'm like —
Tim Ferriss: All roads lead to Naval.
Shane Parrish: And I was like, "Oh,
my God, I can't give up on this anymore,"
because at the time, I wasn't having fun
doing it. Now I'm having a lot of fun doing
it. Then we created these series of books
called The Great Mental Models. And the idea
behind The Great Mental Models was basically,
what are the big ideas you would've learned in
university and can you apply those outside of the
context of the domain that they were learned in?
And so I think that we've talked about one in
terms of the frame of reference that you're
using to look at a problem matters a lot in
terms of what you see. So we wanted to make that
accessible for people. And then we branched into a
course called Decision by Design. We used to have
an in-person workshop on decision making and we
learned a lot about how people make decisions
in the real world, but COVID shut down all of
these online events. And so we created Decision by
Design as a means to not take the same material we
were doing in person, because what we were doing
in person was very specific to being in person.
It was learning from the people at your table. It
was nontransferable in a way to online. So we took
a more prescriptive approach, which are like,
"What are the things, the practical tools that
people use in the real world to make decisions?"
And we share it with people. And an example of
that is separating problem definition from problem
solution, having two separate meetings for that.
And a lot of people go into these meetings
and they have one meeting and they're like,
"What's the problem?" And then of course, we
work with incredibly intelligent people and most
of them are type A. And so you come in and the
first problem statement that sounds reasonable,
everybody jumps into, "Okay, here's how we solve
for that." Nobody takes a step back and is like,
"Wait, is this problem worth solving?
Is this problem the real problem?"
because we jump into these solutions.
Tim Ferriss: Could you give an example,
could be hypothetical, could be
real-life, of scrutinizing the
problem statement? I think this is really
important. I don't do it nearly as much as
I should. Could you maybe walk through what that
process looks like? If you have an example, great.
Otherwise, it could be in the more abstract.
Shane Parrish: So my belief is that the person who
makes the decision has to come up with a problem
statement for the decision. And that does a couple
things. That forces the person who's making the
decision to really understand the problem. They
can take input from everybody else, but ultimately
they're accountable for taking the problem
statement and determining what that problem is
and communicating what that problem is, and also
identifying which solutions work and fit for that.
When we don't do that and we just sort of throw a
problem on the table, it really backfires.
Tim Ferriss: I'll give you one on my own.
So maybe we can workshop that. So for instance,
I have tons of legacy email addresses, inboxes,
and at least at face value, the story that I tell
is that it is a huge pain in the and there are
different maybe security vulnerabilities and
issues with having different platforms and
things scattered all over the place. The problem
in a sense has not been that well-defined. It's
just overall kind of angsty hand-wringing and
a couple of identified risks. Then we've jumped
straight into solutions. And there are any host
of different solutions that I won't bore you with,
but it's going to take some time. And I think
I have a pretty good beat on what the right
direction is for this. But just for purposes of
using the exercise, how would you scrutinize that?
I come in, I say, "Hey, this is a problem. We
don't have things centralized in one modern
inbox with all of the enterprise-level security
that that would include. Therefore, we should
decommission these following inboxes and blah,
blah, blah." Right? But I'm taking for granted
that is the right definition of the problem.
Shane Parrish: Right, exactly. So it's like,
who's the check and balance on, what are we
solving for? And it goes back to something we
talked about earlier. What direction? Am I getting
closer to the destination and is the destination
the one that I want to get to? So in this case, is
the problem that you're solving, "I want access to
all of these materials through one inbox," or
is the problem something different, which is,
"I don't feel these inboxes are really that secure
and I don't know how to manage them." And the way
that you frame that problem will determine in a
large part what solutions you see as available.
And maybe it's something different. We're just
sort of spitballing this on the spot here.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
Shane Parrish: But your surface area is large,
right? So all these email addresses increase
your surface area of attack if that's the way
that you're thinking about it. And if your goal
is to reduce it, one way of reducing it might
be to consolidate it. One way of reducing it
might be to eliminate them. One way of reducing
it might be something completely different.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally. And this is timely
for me because as I was walking through recording
a screen flow for my team related to this,
I realized about halfway through, because I was
talking about next actions, and I said, "Actually
wait a second, my ultimate objective here is
to spend substantially less time in email."
And I think maybe compared to a reference point
that would be, say, an average of my friends,
I do spend a lot less time in email, but I would
like to spend more time on certain creative
projects and larger needle-moving dedicated blocks
of time, three to four hours for fill-in-the-blank
project or experiment. I realized pretty quickly
that if my advice were implemented directly,
it would just be taking this burden. It's not just
attack vectors, it's also just lots of unsolicited
inbound. It would be taking all of that and
just moving it to a different mailing address.
And I was like, "Okay, that partially solves
one issue, but it does not at all address this
separate issue, which is maybe on some level the
bigger issue, even though I tend to run a little
paranoid, the unsolicited inbound is probably a
bigger problem currently than the attack factor
stuff." I have pretty good security as it stands,
probably excessive security in a lot of respects.
But I realized halfway through trying
to prescribe the solution, I was like,
"Wait a fucking second. I might be giving the
best advice possible for solving the wrong thing."
Shane Parrish: Yeah, totally. Right. And
that is in and of itself a good reason to
separate these things. But also when you're
the boss, your suggestions become direction.
So you might be just thinking out loud, but the
people hearing that are like, "Oh, Tim wants this.
Here's how we solve for this." And then in your
head you're like, "Oh, that sounds like a good
solution," but you've solved the wrong problem.
And so this is why separating these meetings
between what is the problem, can we get clear on
what the problem is? And here's what — you don't
have to go first, but whatever your process
is to get that information out to people in
terms of what they see as the problem, you can
take that, mull it over and be like, "We'll
have another meeting tomorrow and we'll determine
solutions. Or maybe next week if it's not timely."
And people think this slows you down, this is the
biggest thing that I hear when I talk to people
about this is they're like, "Well, that'll just
slow us down and prevent us from taking action."
Actually, the exact opposite is true because it
increases — it's sort of like you're thinking
in terms of speed, but speed doesn't have
a direction. It doesn't matter how fast
you're going. If you're running in circles,
you really want to get to the best outcome
possible in the shortest amount of time with
the least amount of effort. And that means
you're allowing your team to maximize their
thinking. A lot of people don't think well on
the spot. So having these group meetings where
everybody's required to contribute — a lot of
people mull it over. They go for a walk after,
or they're walking home after work that night,
and then they get this idea, this spark and
they're like, "No, I don't see it that way."
And then they can't contribute at that point. So
you've tied one hand behind your back in terms
of maximizing the talent on your team to figure
out what the problem is and then to solve it.
And so it makes a lot more sense to be like, "Hey,
we're going to have a 30-minute meeting here and
a 30-minute meeting here instead of one 60-minute
meeting, and these meetings are going to be highly
structured and we're just going to talk about
what the problem is. Can we agree on what the
problem is? What do you see as the problem? What
do you see into this lens that I don't see? I am
not you. I can't see it." And that's a way also
to get out of this — I don't know. People like
to posture in meetings. It drives me crazy. They
basically repeat the executive summary in their
own words and meetings go nowhere. And so a good
way to avoid that is just to assume that everybody
has read the required material and ask them what
their unique contribution to this problem is that
they don't think anybody else sees. And so now
instead of rewarding just airtime, now you're
rewarding unique contribution to the problem and
you get social signal out of having a unique lens
into the problem, which is much more effective.
Tim Ferriss: That makes perfect sense. And are
there other questions that you find useful in
the problem-defining sessions? For instance,
I can imagine one of the questions that
I would want to ask my team in addition
to emphasizing what you just emphasized,
individual perspective and contribution over
restating the executive summary that was sent
as reading for the meeting to begin with. Is
this really a problem? We're assuming this is
a problem that needs to be solved, but is this
significant enough for us to allocate attention
and resources to it compared to other things?
I'm probably using very clumsy wording,
but what other types of — are there any
other questions that you've
seen be very helpful in these
problem-defining meetings?
Shane Parrish: "And then what?"
is a great question, right?
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Shane Parrish: "If we switch to a new email
platform, and then what?" You can imagine,
you can do a thought experiment on what your
day would look like, but we often neglect all of
these other things, which is like, "This software
doesn't do this thing that I actually do a lot. So
therefore now we have to develop a workaround or
the software's completely different and everybody
has to be trained on it or the software's
not as supported and doesn't update as much."
There's all these lenses. But I love the, "And
then what" question because it's like, "Okay,
if we solve this problem, what state are we in
and what is the cost in terms of time, money,
effort, brain drain?" We don't think about
brain drain very often to solve this problem.
And the bigger your team is, the more you tend to
solve these problems that aren't really problems
because you're like creating busy work for you.
And I think we both run very small teams. And
so we think through, "Okay, if we solve this
problem, then what happens? How do we develop
the most leverage possible?" But I think a lot
of people don't tend to think through that. I've
seen this all the time where organizations I've
worked with have switched out software and they
switch out the software to solve one problem and
they're ignorant to the 67 other problems they
just created by solving that one problem. And
it feels good. It feels like you're doing work,
but at the end of the day, you're in a
worse position than you were in because
you didn't ask yourself, "And then what?"
Tim Ferriss: All right. I'd love to segue
for a minute to automatic rules because for myself
at least, especially running a small team where
the default, I suppose, flow of things is
that a lot of decisions flow to me and I
try not to be an unnecessary bottleneck, but
I have a very small team, a few employees,
and automatic rules and policies are very helpful
here. For instance, I have a blog post I put up,
it's like I'm not reading any new books this year,
which solves a lot of issues as you might imagine.
And I have these blanket policies for at least
five to eight years. I did no speaking engagements
effectively. I've made a few exceptions recently,
but for a long period of time I did none of that.
For another, I think I want to say probably
three to four years, no angel investing. And
these were rules that prevented decision fatigue
and just allowed me a lot more cognitive bandwidth
and emotional and physical bandwidth. So what are
some of your automatic rules? I've got a few here:
work out every day, no days off, invest in an
index fund every month, no meetings before 12.
Do you want to spend maybe a few minutes on those
and then any other examples that come to mind?
Shane Parrish: Before I get into a few
more examples, let's back up for a second.
Automatic rules turn your desired behavior into
your default behavior, and they do it when you're
at your best. And so you can pre-decide a lot of
things. And why are rules effective instead of
just a pre-decision? You need it to be a rule. And
the word rule is very specific and very useful.
And I got this idea from Daniel Kahneman and we
were talking and he said, "I have a rule. I never
say 'Yes' on the phone." And he was explaining why
he had just told somebody that he'd talk to them
again tomorrow and follow up with them and they
had asked him to do something. And I was like,
"That's really interesting. Why do you have
that rule?" And he said, "That rule is so
that I don't end up saying 'Yes,' because I
feel social pressure to say 'Yes' to these
things and I want to please other people."
All of us want to please other people. And
he's like, "I learned over years..." and this is
fascinating, will blow your mind, will change your
life. He's like, "I learned over years, people
don't argue with rules and I follow them." So
we're taught our whole life to follow rules,
but we've never thought of how can we create
rules for ourself that we just follow when we're
at our worst when we're in the worst situation
possible? We all know no matter how bad our day
is, we shouldn't speed on the highway because
it's against the rules. What we don't think
about is how do we use rules to our advantage?
A great example, I had a friend who basically
lost a whole bunch of weight using this rule
and he basically said, "Every time I go out for
dinner..." and he ate out for dinner a lot in his
life for work. He's like, "My rule is I order the
healthiest thing on the menu and I don't drink."
Tim Ferriss: Meaning no alcohol.
Shane Parrish: Meaning no alcohol, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Shane Parrish: And he didn't order dessert.
That was his third rule. And if you think about
dessert, dessert's an interesting one because I
think we can all relate to it. You go out, you
celebrate with your friends, the wine comes out,
the champagne comes out, the dessert comes
out, and all of a sudden you're doing things
that maybe the best version of you doesn't
want to do, but you're in a social situation,
you feel pressure. You can tell people, I'm not
eating dessert, I don't want dessert tonight. But
that relies on willpower. So every time you
say, "I don't want dessert tonight," you're
using willpower to get out of that situation.
And eventually, everybody loses the battle
with willpower. So how can you create a system to
get out of this willpower thing where it's like,
"I'm not using willpower, I create an automatic
rule. I don't eat dessert. That's my rule."
And when you say that to your friends, you might
have to say it twice, but they definitely push
back a lot less as long as you're consistent
with that rule. But that rule puts you in the
best position possible for success. And I
have a couple of these rules. When I am out
after a talk with the people who organize the
talk, my rule is I stopped drinking at 9:00,
nothing could happen after 9:00. And so you just
choose in advance. And a great way to think about
this again is going back to what we talked about
earlier, direction, destination. What does a
person who achieves this destination, what do they
behave like? Can I create automatic rules in my
life? And they're so context-specific,
they're so specific to you because
they're also things you don't do naturally.
I hate working out, but I want to be healthy.
It's really important to me to be healthy. And
I was struggling, and this is where the work
out every day rule came in. I was struggling to
go three times a week because I would get into
this negotiation with myself. And that negotiation
was like, "I normally work out on Wednesdays," but
that little voice in my head is like, "You didn't
sleep well last night. You have a lot of work on
your plate." And then all of a sudden I'm like,
"I'll do extra tomorrow." I'll catch myself doing
this sort of talk and I'm, "Why am I negotiating
with myself? Who's in charge here? I'm in charge
of this situation." And so I changed it and
I'm like, "I am going to work out every day.
And it doesn't mean I go to the gym every day
and it doesn't mean I go for 60 minutes. I can
reduce the scope or duration of my workout,
but I'm going to work out every single day."
And that workout might be a five-mile walk,
it might be something else, it doesn't matter.
But there's going to be some form of exercise
involved. And that single rule has changed so
many people's lives that I've shared it with you
because you start exercising every day because the
negotiation in your head now is like, "What do I
fit in today? How can I fit this in?" It's not,
"Should I work out?" It's like, "Oh, I don't have
a lot of time. Maybe I'll just do 20 minutes.
Maybe I'll just go to the gym and do squats."
And all of a sudden you get in this habit,
you're consistently working out, so your health
starts to get a lot better. It's mind-blowing
how this simple principle can have profound
impact. Do you have any rules for yourself?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I have so many.
Shane Parrish: I want to hear some of yours.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Well, I will say that as
you're talking, my father for instance has in
the last — it's been very fast actually, maybe in
the last two to three months has lost 50 pounds.
And he's done that by following the slow-carb
diet in The 4-Hour Body as described by The
4-Hour Body. People can find it online, certainly
without having to buy any book. But the key there,
one of the keys, is having a very straightforward
rule. And the rule is you don't have to give up
your favorite foods for the rest of your life.
You just have to give up your favorite foods
for six days at a time and you have a set cheat
day every week. And that also allows you to get
off the hook or to successfully negotiate with
yourself or with your friends because you say,
"It's my policy that I only have
cheat day once a week on Saturday."
So if you want to have dessert, booze, whatever
it might be — not in my dad's case with those two,
but I'm happy to do it, but it's got to be on a
Saturday. And then all of a sudden the negotiation
is over. There is no negotiation. I would say
when I am my best self, which I am right now —
let's see. Another rule would be if I want
to follow the slow-carb diet, have pre-made
meals ready to go in the refrigerator for at
least three to four days at a time. So I did
that today for instance, because if I start to
run out of food and I'm picking at the dregs of
whatever I have sitting around and I'm starting to
starve, but lo and behold I have a podcast to do,
I'm going to go buy something fast that
is not going to conform to the diet.
Batch-processing buying or having bought food
so that it's ready to go. I mean I have a lot
of policies. So as it relates to inbound,
and I have an autoresponder that kicks back
a lot of this stuff, I'll tell you some of
the rules that have existed for a while,
generally speaking, no speaking engagements,
and I could explain why that is. That was a
particularly hard one when I made the decision
because speaking engagements for authors who
have bestselling books is very lucrative and it
is, in fact, the main source of income for a lot
of authors. And I just realized categorically
I had to say "No" because it was very hard to
moderate my commitments with speaking engagements.
Shane Parrish: Yeah. And it's addictive, right?
Tim Ferriss: It is addictive.
Shane Parrish: You hop on a plane,
you get this big check, and then
you could do it all over again.
Tim Ferriss: And then you end up booking your
life out nine months in advance and it crowds
out a lot of other things. Like the metaphor of
this apocryphal story of — the professor asks
the students to fit the two rocks and a handful
of pebbles and then the sand into the jar. And
the lesson is you've got to put in the big rocks
first and then the pebbles and then the sand. But
you can't do it the other way around. You can't
do it in any other order or the big rocks won't
fit. And I realized for myself that was true with
speaking engagements. What I did do as an interim
for that is when I would say yes to speaking
engagements, I had a complete barbell approach.
So I would either do free, so it had to be so
incredibly compelling. Maybe that's because
it's cause-based and really aligned with a very
narrow band of things that I commit myself to on
that side, or it had to be a paid gig matching or
above my previous high watermark. So whatever the
highest amount that I had been paid was, it had
to match or exceed that never below. And that
automatically constrained the volume of things
that I could commit to and made it manageable.
And by the way, the people who are willing to do
that were always the easiest to deal with. You
would think maybe intuitively that the people who
pay the most would be the most demanding and the
most difficult. That has not been my experience
at all. It's actually completely the opposite.
I have many other rules. So the "No
new books" would be another one. If
anyone tries to rush me into a decision via
email or on the phone, the answer is "No."
It's not just that I postpone giving an answer,
the answer's "No." If I feel like someone is
rushing me into a decision, the answer is "No."
If someone's rushing me because reading between
the lines, they don't want me to have enough time
for a proper legal review — a lot of startups do
this. It's very annoying where they'll send
you docs on Friday afternoon and say, "Well,
we need to close this round and we need to get
signatures back by 10:00 a.m. on Monday." And I'm
like, "Then it's a fucking 'No,' I'm sorry.
I'm an adult and I don't play these games."
So there are a handful of things like that.
I'll give you another one for the podcast and
I'm going to ask you a similar question for
the business side of things for you and the
creative side, but I'd love to hear any. So for
instance, for the podcast, everything is prepaid,
all invoices are prepaid, and that is something
that very few podcasts can do. It's something that
very few podcasts can manage given the business
norms. Generally, it's net 30 or net 60 or some
type of net payment terms. But to manage that,
you either need to have a reasonably large team,
you need to have someone fully dedicated to
chasing down payment or you need to work with
outside agencies to pick up that burden. I didn't
want to deal with any of that. And so I said,
"Look, this is..." I recognize a tradeoff. And
with these rules, I think you would probably
agree there are tradeoffs. There
always are going to be trade-offs.
But if decision is like de-cision, kind of like
incision, like the cutting away, that's fine.
So you're cutting away certain possible outcomes.
But if I make a rule that everyone has to prepay,
a few things happen. Number one, the universe
of possible sponsors we need to consider goes
down dramatically. Secondly, the people who are
willing to do that, again, counterintuitively, are
generally people who are measuring twice, cutting
once, and are going to be the easiest to deal with
later. And we don't always bat a thousand, but
we do pretty well. So those would be some of the
rules. I've got all sorts of other ones.
Shane Parrish: As you were saying that,
there's a couple of things that came to mind.
One is, I can often determine from an initial
outreach of an investment whether I want to
do the deal before I even know the specifics
because it's like, "How fair is this to me?"
And if the deal is one-sided towards you,
an example of which is like, "Hey, I need
this by…" you can't get it legally reviewed,
or you have to get your lawyers working overtime,
"I need it by Monday." Well, I don't want to be a
partner with that person. And so that's —
Tim Ferriss: That's the honeymoon. That's
the honeymoon phase.
Shane Parrish: I know.
Tim Ferriss: Should be easier.
Shane Parrish: So that's an easy
"No." But often when we're investing in a lot
of private businesses that aren't necessarily
startups that are profitable businesses,
I can tell by the valuation, the pitch,
what people are looking for, what their optimal
scenario is, if I want to be a partner with that,
because if you're presenting a deal that isn't
fair to me right now, you're never going to be
fair to me in the future. It has to be win-win.
And people don't understand. There's literally
four permutations of a relationship. There's
win-win, win-lose, lose-win, and lose-lose. And
only one of those permutations can survive time.
And what do we want with time? We want to compound
relationships. You want to invest in companies
where you don't have to review the legal documents
because you trust the people involved, you've
worked with them before, they're consistent,
they show up, they do what they say they're going
to do, and maybe the investment doesn't work out,
but that's not what you're thinking, but you're
not worried about them stabbing you in the back.
And so often we do things that just take us off
this compounding train, and I think it was Naval
who said, "One of the big lessons from compounding
is that all the gains come at the end. They don't
come at the start." And so you have to stay on
this timeline. So every relationship has to be
win-win. And for the podcast we do like no paid
speaking, which is — it's so interesting. I'm sure
you get these pitches too. It's like, "Here,
I'll give you 100 grand to come on your show,
I'll pay in advance, yada yada." And then I
always look up these people and I'm like, "Oh,
now I know the podcasts that accept money for
guest speakers." But we do the same thing with
this prepaid stuff, and this came back to bug
us because I'm a high-trust person. I operate
on trust. I don't want to be in business with
you if we need a contract. That's generally my
motto. It doesn't mean we don't have contracts,
but it means if I feel the need of a contract,
it's an easy "No" for me. And so —
Tim Ferriss: If you need a contract to
protect you from someone you don't really
trust, you're playing a gambler's game.
Shane Parrish: But often you don't
even think that you don't trust them,
but you'll think of the contract and then you'll
need a contract. And that's the first indication
that something's amiss in this relationship.
And so, we've never used advertising contracts,
but during COVID, this came back to bite us
because we would invoice a lot of our advertisers
once a year and we invoiced them on March 31st —
after we have delivered all of their advertising
for the past year. And we've worked with
people for years and then all of a sudden we're
delivering these invoices March 31st, 2020. And
people are like, "We're not paying that." And I'm
like, "Whoa, what do you mean we're not paying
this? That doesn't make any sense. We've worked
together for four years. How is this even
possible? Am I missing something?" And they're
like, "Basically, sue me." And I'm like, "Ooh."
Tim Ferriss: Fun.
Shane Parrish: "What is going on here? This
is crazy." Interestingly enough, a few of them
have come back and tried to advertise with us
and they're like, "We'll pay our old invoice."
And I'm like, "You should pay that and then
we'll talk, but there's no way I'm going to
sign up to work with you again."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. No, thanks.
Shane Parrish: The speaking thing — again, that
comes back to, "Where do I want to get to in
life?" I do the exact same thing except I sort of
limit it. I'm like, "Here's the number of speaking
engagements I can do this year. It's like six
or 10 depending on the year, depending on what
I want to do that year." And then we use price as
a function to modulate that in the sense of — I
love your high watermark idea. I think that's
really important, and that's a great way that I
had never thought about doing it, and I just use,
"Hey, I only do six a year. Here's the cost." And
it just eliminates most people, and to your point,
the people that say "Yes" are the easiest freaking
people to deal with in the world, and they want
you there and there's no 16 hours of pre-calls
and all of this other stuff.
Tim Ferriss: No.
Shane Parrish: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: No. They've decided
they want you as a speaker. You're not one of 10.
They will gladly accept. That's when you get into
all sorts of comms overload and brain damage. If
you had to double down on one or two things you
are already doing, what would you double down on?
Shane Parrish: Oh, definitely the email list. I
think that that is the key, right? If you can
pick one primary focus for this, you need to be
able to reach your audience, you need to be able
to communicate with them. And however you do that,
whether you do it building it through Twitter
or Instagram, you want all past to lead back
to your email list. And the person who does
this the best is James Clear. He constantly —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, he is a machine.
Shane Parrish: He's a machine, right? Instagram
points back to his website, Facebook points
back to his website, Twitter — he's just really,
really smart at this. So if you're going to model
yourself off somebody and you want to build an
email list, he's the person to sort of think
about. You also have a huge audience for email.
Tim Ferriss: I do, yes. I'm very, very grateful.
Very methodical too. I've thought about it.
Although, like you, didn't think about it at
all until a few things happened, including feed
burner, sending a notification, "We were about
to turn off everything," and then began emailing
however long ago it was, which has been a great,
actually a really fun process for me because
5-Bullet Friday serves as my diary effectively.
Shane Parrish: Yes, totally.
Tim Ferriss: I don't have a separate diary, so
it's fun to look back two years ago. It's like
there's one that comes out every week and I
can look back two years and go, "Oh, yeah,
I remember that." That exact week's locked
in the amber. It's like some prehistoric
mosquito or something, and I can revisit.
Shane Parrish: And you also realize how
stupid you were, or at least I do when I look
back at some of my old newsletters, I was like,
"Oh, what was that?" But that's also a really
positive sign because you're growing. But going
back to the question, I would focus on email
and I would ditch podcasts at this point and
just double down on email and long-form
content counterintuitively on the web.
Tim Ferriss: How would you do — can you give
— let's just say, I was like, wish granted,
boom, poof podcast just dissolves into the
ether with a rainbow and some whinnying of
unicorns and it's all wonderful, but that has
come to a close and then you're doubling down
on email and — what was the phrasing that
you just used? But it was sort of online —
Shane Parrish: Long-form content.
Tim Ferriss: Long-form content. How
would you do that? What might things
look like in the next three months if
you were doubling down on those things?
Shane Parrish: Yeah, so just for context,
I was operating under the
guise of starting from scratch.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Got it.
Shane Parrish: I would pick a vector,
and that vector would be sort of creating
content that people find useful and timeless,
and it's super important. The word timeless
is really important there because you want
the compounding effect. You want the cumulative
effect to work to your advantage. So if you're
creating content that is easily consumed but no
longer relevant in a week, a month, even a year,
then that content can't work for you when you're
not working. But a lot of the stuff that you do
on your blog, and definitely the stuff that we
do on FS Blog is — it's always relevant. It's
evergreen. We just re-aired that interview with
Naval Ravikant. We recorded it six years ago.
People thought it was recorded yesterday. We don't
talk politics. We avoid these certain subjects.
I think what I would do is I would focus on
creating the best content I could. I would
get people who come to the website to give me
their email address, and I would think about
not expanding that surface area, just creating
better, "How do I write the next article? How
do I make it useful?" And then spending a lot of
time thinking about, "How do I share that? Where
do people who are like me, who will find this
interesting, where do they hang out? How can I let
them know about it?" But I wouldn't go in — what
people tend to do is, the two mistakes I see in,
I guess if people are trying to do what we've
done or we're doing, is they spread themselves
too thin. So they're like, "Oh, I'm going to
start a blog. I'm going to create a podcast.
I'm going to just do an email newsletter."
And it's like, "Man, you have no idea how much
work all that stuff is, good luck." And the other
thing that I see a lot of people doing is just
thinking it's going to be easy. And so they get
into this trap of like, "Oh, I said something
that's really popular. I wrote an article that's
really popular, and now I'm going to write
another one on the same thing and another one
on the same thing." And by the end of the year,
it's like you're just posting the same stuff. And
whether that's aggressive tweets or something,
you become something you wouldn't read. And so
I don't look at stats on the website. I look at
the email stats once a week, but I never
look at what's the most popular article.
I never want that to guide the next article. I
just really want to follow what I'm interested in,
what I'm curious about, and where my energy is.
And I feel like that a cohort of people will find
that and be like, "Oh, I found my tribe. This is
my person. I'm so glad that there's somebody else
interested in this other than me." And that's
how I think about building it. But you have
to find that thing for you, and I think it's
really, really critical that you don't spread
yourself too thin and try to do everything.
And then you can create these systems in your
life that allow you to do that, which is — let's
say you want to do that and you want to work full
time at the same time, but you want to slowly
build up this body of content that works for you
while you're working. Well, one way to do that is
write every morning from 5:00 until 6:00. And so
you just block off the best hour of your day for
writing. Most people do it the other way. They
block off the worst hour of their day, which might
be at night. And so they come home after all this
baggage and all this work, and then they spend
all their time and effort trying to focus, instead
of actually just letting it flow and writing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I mean as far as rules go, the
evergreen/timeless piece has always been important
to me for all the reasons that you're mentioning,
including the energy-giving, because if we were
to look at it from a different perspective,
if you are competing for attention — and I don't
want to make it seem zero-sum, but if you are
trying to draw people to what you are producing in
some capacity, if you choose timely, news-driven
topics, or people, or stuff that's getting
sensationalized, or stuff that's really
controversial and polarizing, you are stepping
into the bloodiest, most crowded arena imaginable.
The timeless stuff, or the evergreen stuff,
is hard to do. You're also capping, I think,
a lot of your growth, frankly. But that's okay.
Shane Parrish: Well, you grow slower, but you
increase the timeline you have for growth, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Shane Parrish: The runway becomes longer even
if you're growing slower in the short term.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly. You have compounding gains
in the form of audience growth and so on that
will be more sustained as opposed to fair-weather
readers or listeners who are just chasing whatever
the algorithm serves them on any given day,
in any given minute. So question just on the
compounding thing because Naval, of course, is
an incredible investor. I'd love to know a bit
about how you personally think about investing.
It seems like you do some private deals. Also
seems like you invest in an index fund
or index funds. Could you say more about
that? And could you also speak to whether or
not you think investing indices, I guess it is,
has substantially changed now that, as I
understand it, big tech factors vary heavily
into at least some of the indices or indexes, I'm
not sure which the proper word is to use here.
But how do you personally think about investing?
Shane Parrish: So I use the cash flows from Farnam
Street to invest. And one of the advantages
to being you or me that a lot of people don't
have is deal flow. So you get deal flow that
the best VCs in the world would be envious of
and to some extent, so do I. And so you've created
this vehicle that wasn't primarily for investing,
but has this big benefit to it where
you're able to get deal flow because
of all the other things you do, not because
you're focused on deal flow every day. And so
I wanted to use that to my advantage in
terms of how do we get into good deals?
How do I create something sustainable?
How do I create something long-term,
and how do I apply this knowledge that I'm having
fun applying? I like investing. I don't do a ton
of VC investing. I try to invest mostly —
In terms of check size, it's almost all
allocated to companies that are making
money or something that I really understand
the path of. I occasionally invest with
friends. But when I invest with friends,
my rule is — go back to rules. I write that
investment off to zero the minute I write the
check, because I never want my investment with
friends to affect our friendship. So in my head,
it's just a zero the minute the check —
Tim Ferriss: It's a donation.
Shane Parrish: Yeah, it's a donation to them. And
I'd rather be wrong supporting a friend than right
not supporting them. That doesn't do anything
for our friendship. And so I think about the
things that I understand and then diversifying
— because I don't use outside money. There's
no outside investors, there's Shane. And so
I think about how do I survive? Not how do I
maximize my returns in the short term? How
do I maximize my returns in the long term?
Rule number one for Warren Buffett, don't lose
money. Rule number two is, see rule number one.
So I want to diversify when it makes sense, but
I also want to be in a position where I can flow
to whatever makes sense. We have a real estate
company where we invest in real estate, but we'll
wait until there's a lot of distress until we put
more money into that, and then I can be patient,
I can go years without making an investment.
Tim Ferriss: Is that mostly residential,
commercial? What kind of stuff?
Shane Parrish: All residential.
Tim Ferriss: All residential?
Shane Parrish: Yeah. So it's multifamily at scale.
And so I just want to do things where there's
a long runway, I'm working with people I trust,
the financial returns are sort of justifying the
investment. But also the advantage to being you or
I or this one-person team, is you can put yourself
in a position where you don't have to — like you
said, you stopped VC investing for years. You
don't have to make an investment. Nobody is
emailing you going, "Tim, why haven't you made
an investment?" Nobody is emailing you going,
"What are you doing with my money?" All of a
sudden you can just let cash pile up on the
balance sheet. You can just let it accumulate
in the bank account. And then when you see an
opportunity where the risks and rewards sort of
indicate that this is favorable and you have an
edge in this particular investment, then you
can write a large check in 12 hours. There's
no investment committee to go through, there's
nothing to do, it's just you making a decision.
And so I like that aspect of it, and I think
about it that way. I do the index fund thing,
it's sort of outside all of that, which is just
— I like fail safes. I don't know about you,
but I hide money from myself at times. So the
real estate company, when I log into my bank,
it doesn't even show up on the list of companies
we have, it's just this separate entity that
I log into once a year to get the financial
statements for the accountants. But mentally
I've convinced myself it doesn't exist, which
I think is a really powerful way for me because
I don't want to convince myself that I'm
smarter than I am at any of this stuff,
and I also always want to think that I'm in
a worse position than I am because I really
want to increase and improve my position.
Tim Ferriss: And has your thinking on index
investing changed over the years or is it like I
see oftentimes, people saying "It's not timing the
markets, it's time in the markets," so just keep
buying, right? Just keep buying, with respect to
an index or any number of different index
funds. How has your thinking remained the
same or changed with respect to index investing?
Shane Parrish: Well, the weighting of the top
companies has definitely caused
me a little bit of hesitation.
What I do with indexing is, while I invest in an
index fund every month, I don't always invest the
same amount of money in the index fund. So if you
want to think of this sort of very simplistically,
when there's panic and nobody wants to invest, I
tend to put more money in. And when everybody's
investing and we're reaching all-time highs, I
tend to put less in. I don't know if that's an
effective strategy for everybody else, it's just
sort of what I do to regulate money going into
index funds. But what we haven't seen with index
funds that worries me is with the rise of index
funds, we haven't seen massive forced selling
of index funds and how that impacts the funds.
And so I'm actually sort of counterintuitively
thinking the rise of activist investors,
they just went through this 10-year spell where
they didn't outperform and they're really smart.
I'm kind of thinking, "Oh, now might be the
time to allocate more money into that pocket."
Because I think that there might be an opportunity
when index funds are no longer what we're thinking
of as index funds, and they always go up and all
of a sudden stock picking comes back in vogue. And
you can buy some of them. You can buy Perishing
Square at — I don't know what today's price is,
but a 30 percent discount to its net asset value.
And I remember doing this during COVID. So March
2020, Bill Ackman got on TV and he's like, "I
have these asymmetric bets." And I was like,
"Oh, Bill is a really smart guy. I know him."
So I started looking at the net asset value of
Pershing Square, and it's like the market's
tanking at the same time the net asset value
is going parabolic. So I was just buying all the
shares I could, and that's all publicly available
information. But you have to be in a position
to take advantage of that information with cash,
otherwise, you're for selling something to
do it. How do you think of an index fund
investment? What do you do with your money?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, my God. Yeah, I'm in the
process of tremendously — I don't want to say
de-risking because that would presume that I
accurately can identify and understand
all the various risks out there,
which kind of would be a ridiculous thing for me
to claim. But I have realized that many, many,
many of my investments are highly correlated. And
I've always been growth first. And I have friends,
I'm not going to name names, but friends who
are like, "Look, there is no role for bonds
in your portfolio. You don't need the cash. You
should be 100 percent go, go, go." And these are
very smart people who have done very, very well
over long periods of time. And intellectually,
let's first of all say I'm not a financial
advisor, I do not recommend anyone take that
advice, but this is advice that a few
of my friends were giving to me based
on their understanding of my life.
And what I came to realize is that
while academically that might be true, it
actually makes it harder for me to sleep. So
I am making a number of decisions right now, that
for anyone who is type A super-driven, successful,
growth-minded investor would look at askance and
consider probably pretty stupid. But for me, I'm
realizing number one, I don't need to chase extra
gains, necessarily. I mean, I have areas where I
feel like I have informational advantage with
early-stage stuff. If I decided two years from
now I want to double, triple down, or 10 x down
on that sector, I could do that pretty easily.
So I'm going to try and experiment for a few
years. I'm in the process of doing this right
now where I'm going to be moving a lot of my cash
from growth positions. I can't do that in all
cases because a lot of my stuff is locked up in
privates, but I'll be moving a lot from areas that
are high growth, but that are high complexity and
difficult for me to understand. That applies to
a bunch of stuff overseas where I don't think the
world is as siloed as it once was. I mean, Nassim
Taleb and I were talking about this recently,
where the idea that you're protected from the
ups and downs of say, the US by being in Western
Europe is kind of ridiculous. And that's true even
further afield. So I'm trying to, I suppose
at this point, optimize for sleep. That's it.
And I'm sure I'm going to look back a few years
from now and say, "Fuck, man, the opportunity cost
was so high." But there are periods of time where
I've been red hot and I've been able to strike.
Most notably when I had much less cash
in sort of 2008 to 2012, let's say,
which was an incredible vintage and a period for
startup investing. If someone were to give me my
starting capital that I had then now, even
adjusted for inflation, say, "Go get them,
tiger," I would not succeed. I really don't think
I would be able to do what I did then. The world
has just changed. The valuations and the deal
structuring, all of these things have changed.
However, there have been these pockets where I've
been able to make good decisions only because I
have extra powder. And right now I feel like I'm,
or at least over the last handful of years, pretty
fully deployed where I could get in a position
if I screw up my planning where I'm a forced
seller or at least a distress seller. Not
in any kind of bet the farm way, but it adds
stress and I think that after so long and really
focusing so hard and for periods of time working
so hard to get to a point where I don't need to,
fortunately, and there's a lot of luck involved,
but worry about my expenses. To manufacture
complicated strategies for life that add
that stress back in is kind of ridiculous, it's
completely absurd. So I'm trying not to do that.
And I noticed among my friends, almost all of them
do this and we laugh about it. It's like, "Oh,
yeah, I managed to remove this stress." And they
figure out a really sophisticated self-sabotaging,
subconscious way to add all that stress right back
in. So that's a long answer to a short question.
Shane Parrish: Well, it's so interesting because
you hit on a couple things there that really
resonate with me in how I approach things. The
first was you were like, "The opportunity cost is
huge." Well, no, because you're only considering
the measurable opportunity cost. You can't measure
your sleep at night as easily.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Shane Parrish: Right?
Tim Ferriss: Right, right.
Shane Parrish: And so that decision makes perfect
sense. Why risk what you have and don't need for
what you don't have and don't want to begin
with? It doesn't make sense to take those
risks. When you're young, it makes sense to take
a lot of risk in order to sort of get ahead,
but as you get older and you have more to lose,
sure, you can keep pushing that button as long
as you want, but at some point it doesn't
always have to be a pure financial decision.
An example of that is when I left working for the
intelligence agency, I had this amazing pension,
and they're like, "Well, starting at 55, we're
going to pay you this much money every year."
And it's a pretty big sum of money. I worked a lot
of years there and got a really decent salary. And
I was like, "No, cash it in." And my accountant
was like, "What do you mean cash it in? That is
the worst financial decision you can make." And
I'm like, "It's the worst financial decision,
but it's the best psychological decision because
if I know somebody's coming to save me, I'm
going to behave differently. I need all the chips
on the table in front of me and I need to know
it's on me. And I know that doesn't make sense
to you, but for me, that's the only way that I'm
going to have a shot at being successful at this."
Tim Ferriss: Also, not to state the obvious,
but let's go for it. Past shelter, food, all the
basics, and then a couple of extracurricular fun
things here and there. Beyond that — even
for that, the extracurriculars. Presumably,
the money is used to improve your quality of life.
So if you're doing things to make money that are
decreasing your quality of life, it's sort of
antithetical to the whole name of the game —
Shane Parrish: 100 percent.
Tim Ferriss: — in some respect. Which
I'm saying in part to remind myself of, because
making a lot of decisions right now, which for me
provoke a visceral angst because I have been
so — during periods, I've made some terrible
decisions too, let's be very clear. I've made
some very terrible, very expensive decisions,
but there have been these sprints of say, four
or five years where I've made a series of very
good decisions that tend to be opportunistic.
The podcast is a great example. That was nowhere
in a three, five, or 10-year plan. It was very
opportunistic and the timing was really fortunate.
And therefore, when I start moving
as I am right now, quite a bit into,
let's just call it safer stuff. That's up for
debate, but let's just call it safer stuff.
It's very counter to my conditioned way of
being in the world. Do you know what I mean?
So it's an experiment. I'm also viewing it like,
look, yeah, I'm going to pay a bunch of hits here
and there, and I'm blah, blah, blah, tax this,
tax that. Let's not let that tail wag the dog
if we can avoid it. But I'm going to do it for,
let's just call it two years and see how I feel,
right? If I'm happy I did it, great. And if I'm
sleeping better, great. And if I'm like, "Okay,
that was an interesting experiment, but actually
I want to get back in the fray and roll up my
sleeves and really go at it in this full contact
sport known as all this early stage stuff,"
then fine. It's not a permanent decision.
Shane Parrish: Yeah. I think that's an interesting
way to think about it. I, mean you could also
— if you feel the need to keep going, you've
accomplished so much and you've done really well,
you could also just put enough money aside that
if everything else went to zero, you'd be okay.
Hide that bank account from yourself, basically
invest it in sort of safe, reliable stuff, and
then pretend it doesn't exist and then go nuts.
And then with all the other stuff, you can sort
of play these little mind games on yourself where
it's, oh, all of a sudden I'm worth less. I've got
to make more. Right? And if that's your goal is to
do that — but I'm totally with you in money should
improve the quality of life that you're living.
And a lot of things that that looks like, it's
counterintuitive to most people because it looks
like time. It looks like you're buying time.
Tim Ferriss: I know we're winding to a close
shortly, but I want to ask you perhaps just
broad strokes, how should people think about
becoming better at making decisions? And here's
the backdrop for that. In the room next door, I
have Poor Charlie's Almanack. I love reading about
mental models. However, I sometimes run into this
cognitive indigestion when I try to
force-feed myself too many rules,
cognitive biases, fill in the blank. I get to
a point where I fail from too much information,
not too little information. Just like if a
friend of mine, and this has happened a lot,
who has no exercise habit, no controlled
diet to speak of, comes to me and says,
"Hey, give me an index card with the
20 things I should do to get whatever,
six pack abs by the end of the year." It never
works. It works exactly zero percent of the time.
And I have found that sometimes I try to take
on too much at once. Sometimes I find looking
at decisions retroactively to be helpful, but I'm
not sure — there are people who would say, well,
we don't actually learn that much from our
failures. I think Peter Thiel would probably
underscore that. How would you suggest people go
about getting better at making decisions? What are
some of the approaches or tools in the toolkit?
Shane Parrish: I think we hit on a couple things
during this episode, and I'll tie this in a
second. So most of the time when we know we're
making a decision, we tend to do fairly well in
that moment given the information we have because
we're rational about the sense that — we're mostly
rational. We don't get it perfect, but we're
directionally correct. If you're thinking about
marrying your partner, you know you're making a
decision. If you're thinking about buying a
house, you know you're making a decision. In
those moments, we tend to be more rational. And so
we might be wrong in the end, but we're not really
wrong, especially given the information we have
at the time. We're generally correct. So when it
comes back to general decision making, here's how
you undo yourself, you can marry the best person
in the world for you, but if you don't invest
in that relationship, it all multiplies by zero.
And investing in that relationship becomes not
a decision, right? Because you're not thinking
about it as a decision. You start living with
somebody and then all of a sudden you're arguing
over how you loaded the dishwasher and it
turns into not talking to each other. Well,
if I tap you on the shoulder in that moment and I
say, "Hey, Tim, you're about to put gas or water
onto this situation, what would you like to
choose?" And this is what I do with my kids,
and they're always like, "Oh, water."` But
what I'm really doing is, "Hey, you're making
a decision to escalate here. Is that the decision
you want to be making?" No judgment on my part,
but I'm just going to alert you to the fact
you're making a decision. And that tends to
help a lot in terms of making better decisions.
So the moments that happen in everyday life,
how do we recognize that they are decisions?
And I would say the biggest aid to judgment
in decision-making is the position you're
in at the time you're making a decision.
It comes back to a lot of what we talked
about today. There's three sort of aspects
to decision-making that I think about that are
very counterintuitive, which is the position
you're in at the time you make the decision. Can
you manage your emotions? Not eliminate them,
manage them. Your temperament. You don't want
to be making a decision when you're hungry,
angry, lonely, tired. You don't want to be making
a decision when you're focused on proving yourself
right rather than getting the best outcome.
I have this phrase I remind myself with,
which is "Outcome over ego." Am I focused on
getting the best outcome or am I focused on
satisfying myself and proving myself right?
Because the minute I'm proving myself right,
what tends to happen is I ignore all this
information that says that I'm not right, and then
all of a sudden I'm not focused on the outcome.
So by reminding yourself to focus on the outcome,
you sort of open your idea. And you get this when
you run a business, it tends to be a little easier
in some ways because you're so tied and wed to
this outcome that you're looking for ideas no
matter where they come from, you're looking for
the best idea to get you to the outcome you want.
And the third aspect is sort of thinking
independently. Are you thinking independent
of the circumstances, or are the circumstances
thinking for you? Are you thinking independently
of what the crowd is doing or is the crowd
thinking for you? Because if those are
happening, if circumstances or the crowd are
thinking for you, you're not really thinking
at all. But what do you have to do to think
independently? You have to be well-positioned
so that you can think independently.
Tim Ferriss: All right. One last question
before we land the plane, and that is if it's
possible, what is the short explanation for why
we should write in the age of AI?
Shane Parrish: Writing is the
process by which we realize we don't
understand what we're talking about.
And it's only when you sit down
and put pen to paper or even type
out an idea that you have, a decision you're
making, an idea you're wrestling with,
that you sort of see where you don't understand
it. And the process of writing is not only
refining that idea and helping you reflect on
it, but you actually generate new ideas in the
process of writing. And I think it's so easy.
My kids do this, right? They're just like, "Oh,
insert these little variables into ChatGPT, out
comes an essay." And I'm like, "You can't use
that. You can feed it your essay and ask it where
the weak points are. That's a different way of
using it than getting it to write these essays for
you." But the question they have is, "Why would
I write? This doesn't make sense. This thing
will do it for me and I'll get a good grade."
And the other aspect I would say that's
important to writing is you learn humility,
right? You learn to give up on an idea that
you have. You keep trying to fit this idea in,
and you've probably experienced this too, and you
really want this idea to work. Maybe you have a
great opening sentence to a paragraph, but it
just doesn't make sense and you can't make it
make sense. So you have to give up on it, you
have to delete it. You literally have to delete
something from your mind and be like, "No, that
doesn't make sense." "No, that's not good enough."
And I feel like there's a certain humility
to that that we're almost lacking in today.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you're not going to
be able to examine your own thinking if
the source material is produced by ChatGPT.
Shane Parrish: Yeah. Well, what you're really
doing is you have all these thoughts and you're
making the invisible visible. And by making the
invisible visible, now I can see it. Now I can
play with it. Now I can see where it's weak and
where it's strong and how it interacts with other
ideas I have. But when it's just in your head,
then you can't see it, so you can't reason
with it. You can't play with it. You just
end up playing these mental games with
yourself where you trick yourself into
thinking something that you don't actually think.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I mean, I'm bullish on so many
facets of AI, so I'm not a Luddite who's trying
to keep the horse and buggy at its pinnacle or
anything like that. However, I do think there's
a risk of us subjugating our own faculties in the
same way that most of us have lost the ability to
navigate without Google Maps or some equivalent.
If you remove your long-form thinking and remove
the habit of putting that down in some form such
that you can cross-examine it and identify where
you're just not making any sense. Or maybe there's
a shred of something that comes out spontaneously
that makes a whole lot of sense, but if you
hadn't captured it, you would never would've
noticed it as it passed through your mind.
I can't help but think that you'll be incredibly
weakened over time, and if we're either getting
stronger or weaker, I'd say directionally we
want to go towards the former when possible.
Shane Parrish: Yeah, definitely. One
of the crazy things is writing is
often the process by which we learn to think.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Yeah,
you're not writing down what you think,
you're writing in order to think.
Shane Parrish: Right.
Tim Ferriss: And I was just journaling
this morning, in fact, and one of my lines,
which was borrowed from some of my friends in
the military — super simple. I mean, this is not
an incredibly granular rule, but just as a guiding
philosophy, "Slow is smooth, and smooth is fast."
Do not fucking rush, in other words. When I rush,
I make mistakes. Those mistakes cost me more time
in the long run, just trying to make decisions
quickly before defining the problem correctly.
It's like if you want to be fast in the long term,
it's for me at least, "Slow is smooth, and
smooth is fast." Shane, the new book is — yeah,
it's a good one. Clear Thinking: Turning Ordinary
Moments into Extraordinary Results. People can
find that wherever fine books are sold and people
can find the Farnam Street website at fs.blog,
if I'm not mistaken.
Shane Parrish: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Anything else
that you would like to mention?
Anything you would like to add? Maybe
recommendations or requests of the audience
before we come to a close?
Shane Parrish: Yeah. I mean, I'd love to — if
you want to email me, it's shane@fs.blog.
I read everything, but I don't respond to
everything. I would love to know about sort of
the ideas from this episode that connect to ideas
that you have in terms of decision-making
and positioning, and what your best ideas
are for how you position yourself to sort of
survive in different environments and adapt
to whatever the situation requires.
Tim Ferriss: I dig it. All right,
folks. You've got it. God be with you, Shane
and your inbox, shane@fs.blog. And really nice
to spend some time together, Shane. Thank
you for blocking it out and making the time
to get together. I really appreciate it.
Shane Parrish: This was awesome. Looking
forward to getting together in person soon.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, definitely. And for people
listening, as always, thank you for tuning
in. You can find the show notes including the
Disney diagram we'll hunt down, and everything
else we referred to at tim.blog/podcast. And
until next time, just be a bit kinder than is
necessary. Not only to others, but to yourself.